this series is brought to you by Globe
planets what's going on team you've just
mastered archicad through an incredible
12-part series now it's time to dip your
toes into the water with real-time
rendering software that's right we're
taking you through an intensive course
to learn twin motion it doesn't matter
if you're a beginner or somebody with
some experience we're going to take you
step by step all the way from beginning
and make you an absolute wizard in Twin
lotion so you've downloaded installed
twin motion you've opened up for the
very first time and what you see before
you is a relatively generic open strain
we are using twin motion
2023.1.2 for this tutorial and if it
gets an upgrade in between I'll make
sure to upgrade it and show you guys all
the latest features because twin motion
goes through a series of updates all the
time so this in the first screen you've
ever seen and you have no idea what
you're doing all you have to do is hit
that new scene button otherwise you can
explore some different templates go
through the work or you can even go for
a full learning course but starting off
with twin motion you want to hit that
new scene button let it open up a new
scene and you will see a few things in
front of you episode one is all about
the UI so it is going to be damn boring
but I'm going to try and make it
somewhat fun for you guys by making it a
little bit more entertaining than most
of the other UI experiences out there
let's get started straight away by
talking about the overall experience
bottom left hand corner you have your
library bottom right you have your scene
and you have your properties if you tap
all those items away they're going to be
gone out of sight out of mind and you're
going to be left with a widescreen view
of twin motion to turn them back on
simply come back down to the bottom
scene properties keep them active keep
them open and if you also want to turn
on statistics you can see how your
computer is running and based on the
amount of demand you're trying to draw
out of it by using twin motion at the
moment I'm going okay I'm pretty good
there's not really too much Demand on my
computer at the moment so let's drop
that statistics menu I don't really need
it and work our way through the rest
on the right hand side you have the X Y
and Z object and as well as the view
sets but neither of those two crash hot
too amazing at the moment so we leave
them off what you do want to have is
your library your scene and your
properties those three are critical and
you're going to use them time and time
again let's start with the basics of
twin motion you've got this screen open
but how and what do you do left click on
an object you'll select that object in
particular you'll see it automatically
highlights the object in the scene
finder so I've clicked on a one meter
sphere tapping the escape button on the
keyboard is going to get you out of that
selection click on anything else escape
and you can repeat that process time and
time again on the right hand side you
see all of these little eye icons you
can click them on and off individually
or you can group them together and turn
them off entirely if you hate the
starting base and you don't want it in
your scene because let's be honest
nobody really does you can smash the
delete button and it's gone it's
completely disappeared from twid motion
if you want it back just like every
other program command or control Z
brings it back to life now if you've
ever played video games in the past
especially at first person shooter
you're going to know how to use twin
motion relatively quickly right clicking
allows you to pan around so click and
hold and you're going to be able to look
around your camera as if you're in a
first person shooter game the w a s and
D keys are going to let you walk around
and move around freely you can also use
the left right up and down arrows on
your keyboard it's just a little bit
harder to navigate since typically your
right hands on your mouse your left
hands on the left side of the keyboard
and you don't want to be reaching all
the way over on this ID keyboard if
you're moving a little bit too slowly in
any direction so I'm pressing the S key
to go back and the WT to go forward you
can also hold the shift keys
simultaneously and it will start running
a little bit quicker so it is an
in-between phase of what I'm about to
show you next if you're still going too
slowly you can use the number one two
three four five or six on your keyboard
to increase the speed so if I click on
this little eye icon up the top I can
turn on my navigator let's go show
Navigator
that Navigator is basically going to
explain everything I just said so far
except uh up and out down so next to
your
wsa and D Keys you also have the Q and
the E Keys which is Q goes up e goes
down if you press the one on your
keyboard and now I'm holding the a key
to go left you can see how slow it's
moving across like a little snail you
tap the number two that speeds up a
little bit we're getting a little bit
quicker maybe a toddler's crawling Pace
you get three we're starting to walk
maybe a little limp but still a decent
walk tap four okay now we're jogging
we're really moving across the page you
tap fire let's go back in the other
direction damn we're going on a bicycle
or a car or something we're flying you
tap six and you're gone E6 is basically
your Superman if you want to fly around
this page left right up down and move
600 kilometers in one second and well
tap seeks on your keyboard and you'll be
able to go anywhere in a matter of
seconds generally speaking three or four
are going to be your primary movement
speeds around residential housing and
single projects five and six biggest
cities bigger models if you really want
to zoom in close to a detail you might
go into one and really zoom in and
really pan slowly so you can get that
experience of whatever you're trying to
achieve so maybe it's a beautiful camera
motion panning away something cinematic
like that which I'll teach you later on
in this series but you might need that
one two and three option later down the
track so it's good to know all of those
options if you're used to being all over
the shop and not knowing where to go but
you really want to just walk around this
like a human you can tap that I icon
once again and hit the pedestrian mode
because currently we are are in drawing
mode so let's go pedestrian mode and it
will smash you to the ground q and E
won't work anymore you're simply just
going to be able to walk around look
around and make your way up and down
surfaces so if you're in a video game
and you're climbing on some stairs it'll
let you do all of that for now let's go
back to drone mode so we can fly around
our scene like fpv drones all right I've
already talked for a hell of a long time
and you've learned very little but
hopefully you've been entertained at
least somewhat in the process when we're
talking about boring UI stuff if we hit
this settings icon again we can close
that Navigator entirely or we can change
our presets so they are similar to our
modeling software so if you're used to
archicaded Revit you can change the
presets and go ahead and act like you're
still in that software it helps
transition your brain from the two
softwares so it is sometimes good to
change over but I'm just going to assume
everybody is on Twin motion editor I'm
going to close that panel make it
disappear and get rid of it completely
on the left hand side you're going to
see a series of icons each one stupidly
self-explanatory if you don't know what
the objects icon is well come on it's
going to have objects inside it but
let's break him down inside materials
you have another series of icons each
material like glass is going to have a
101 different options for you to have
glass now the more attention to detail
you pay around which actual materials
you're selecting and how you apply them
is going to result in a much better
render if you're new to the game and you
don't even know how to use one of these
materials which let's be honest that's
wide here all you need to do is left
click drag it and drop it where you want
it to be so I didn't want that little
Stone marble looking thing I wanted that
to be a mirror drag and drop it let it
go let's do the same thing with frosted
glass and you can see it turns into
frosted glass now the properties panel
on the right hand side changes as you
change your material I won't dive too
much into properties in this video we'll
go into that when we start talking about
materials and custom materials as well
coming back out of materials again you
have so many options to choose from even
things like car paint you can have a
stunning gold car paint and then you can
even make this little concrete block
turquoise if you wanted to undo and back
concrete we go to come out of this menu
and go back to where we were a second
ago you'll see the link tree starting to
be created at the top we can either dive
back into materials or jump straight
back into our library to go back to the
home panel as twin motion has gotten
better and more powerful more and more
options have become available for
materials not only do we have materials
here but we also have it in mega scans
so if you go Mega scans surfaces you'll
find a whole bunch of new surfaces
available to download through Mega scans
so spend your time finding materials you
like but materials are here and they're
also in mega skin ends vegetation is
very much the same
if you click on vegetation you're going
to have all of the standard twin motion
vegetation all the trees flowers grass
rocks Etc you're going to have quite a
nice selection of beautiful plants as
well so not discrediting twin motion at
all they have excellent variety but they
have a generic variety that gets thrown
in and out quite often hence why Globe
plants has come on board but let's take
any of these trees right click once
right click again and your tree has
magically appeared in your scene it's
casting a shadow it's looking absolutely
great now I didn't say inside vegetation
you have one option in mega scans you
also have 3D plants Mega scans doesn't
have too many trees it's more kind of
ground cover succulents shrubs and those
sorts of things but you might be able to
get a cactus so let's get this little
Cactus out here let's download that let
that download right click it click once
more Let it create the object from Mega
scans and we have a teeny tiny Cactus
dropped in to our environment as well
now going back to our main library that
was one option vegetation was one option
Mega scans was another option sketch fan
has a couple bits and pieces in nature
and plants as well
but best of all if you had to use a
library you've got gone into Globe
plants you've purchased something that
you really really like you can then grab
one of the trees drag and drop it into
the environment and then you have a
beautiful high resolution High poly tree
available to you again just like
materials you have three different ways
to get stunning objects into twin motion
very quickly this whole Library section
is going to host basically everything
the left hand panel is going to be where
you spend most of your time in Twin
motion either through materials
vegetation objects lighting or even hdri
Skies
all of these we will cover it in
absolute detail throughout this video
but today we're just focusing on the
generic basics of the UI now that you
know the library is available to you on
the left hand side you can keep that in
the back of your mind we can start
talking about the rest of the scene on
the right hand side you have your scene
Navigator you've seen Navigator is like
Photoshop is a series of folders
libraries and layers how you want to
activate them how you want to use them
how you want to structure it completely
up to you nobody should be defining how
you create the layers what you can and
what you can't have in Twin motion
you're always going to have your scene
starting off at the top your starting
ground down the bottom your starting
landscape which is a recent Edition in
Twin motion and that starting base we
can delete all of those they're not
important sometimes you keep your
starting ground sometimes don't say I'm
with the landscape and the background
now just above the scene you're going to
have Ambience if you select Ambience
you'll see our properties manager once
again change and give us so many more
options to make completely overwhelming
for newcomers but hey that's what we're
here for
if I undo a couple times I'll be able to
bring my starting base back and this
will articulate a few of my points a
little bit better twin motion is a
real-time rendering software so as you
change something it changes it in real
time and it gets better with every
update a prime example is the global
lighting illumination the time of day
right now is set to 10 30 am if I left
click and simply drag the slider across
you'll see the entire environment change
the Sun the Shadows The Depths
everything slowly change I'm not sure
where the sun's just setting at 9 00 PM
but we're starting to have some
beautiful golden light come through and
then slowly that light Fades as we go
into night time and your stars begin to
twinkle you start to get that Moonlight
as it gets later and later in the
evening but it is a real time rendering
software so regardless of where you
slide this slider it is going to mimic
that exact environment now if you've
ever asked yourself what is the
difference between a high quality render
and an average render you see all over
Instagram well the difference is the
quality the care and the assets
that's why I've teamed up with globe
plans to be able to give you an
incredible library of the world's best
3D photorealistic vegetation trees
shrubs and everything in between are
these Globe plants for a very long time
now you've seen them in my videos before
and finally we've come together to be
able to actually bring you a series
worthwhile so if you're looking for some
incredible 3D plants regardless of where
you are situated around the world it
doesn't matter if you're in America
Australia Africa Europe they've got all
of the plants available for every single
person around the globe so make sure you
check out Globe plants in the
description down below the link is there
for your convenience just like the time
of day you can change the weather as
well the weather
stupidly simple Slide the little slider
across and it starts to rain it stops
the clouds become more and more and
basically you run through the seasons if
you've got it raining and you want a
miserable little day you've got this
little beach umbrella or you put your
snowman underneath too so you can change
it from freezing cold in the beautiful
winter snow falling down you can have a
very magical scene
and adjust your lighting however you see
fit perfect midday look at that
absolutely stunning real-time rendering
snow falling once again we'll dive into
weather and hdrs guys and all of that
later down the track just be conscious
that's where it is location along the
bottom is going to set your North Point
if you need to adjust where North is
based on your project always very
helpful and as well as the details you
can actually pinpoint it to your exact
location so now we're somewhere in the
middle of Europe in the heart of
European summer we're also going to have
our HDR environment which we'll get to
later our Horizon which if we enable and
hide our starting landscape you see a
beautiful background pop in it is quite
lovely a nice little city you can also
drag the slider across to rotate that
around click the picture change it to
mountains if you want change it to
Countryside whatever you want you can
have a beautiful little town it is
generally quite nice and quite appealing
to use so if you wanted to create a
little background have some mountains in
the background have a city further in
the background and then some more snow
you can do that completely your scene
completely up to you but for now let's
turn it off turn our starting landscape
back on and close the Horizon and open
up our ocean unsure why you'd have that
ocean right here in this scene but it's
there you tap ocean it's active and you
can drag that slider to lower the depth
of the ocean or increase the depth of
the ocean as well so there your little
Pontoon you've just created your own
little magical Island
sliding back up We Can Make It Rain we
can make it snow
I don't know why it was snow but you can
do it so all of these settings basically
are your main UI in Twin motion we
haven't discussed is when you select on
an object so let's select this little
sphere you can either click on it or you
can select it in the scene Navigator
you'll see an X Y and Z axis appear
up the top by pressing the Tab Key we're
going to switch through multiple options
you don't have to press tab you can
click through them tab is just an easier
way once you get used to the settings
and the controls so by default you're on
the little move tool if you want to move
it up you just hover over the right
arrow click if you want to move it on
the red and the Green Arrow but you
don't want to move it specifically in
that direction you can select in between
those two shapes and just move it around
freely if you want to rotate it you can
select the rotation bar and rotate it
all the way around press tab once you'll
get the multiple rotation axis tool so
you can select any three of these access
points or any three of the rotation
tools so we can swing around however we
like and last but not least if you tap
tab once more you'll get three accesses
with three squares at the top all these
squares are and they allow you to
elongate or adjust this sphere or any
shape any object however you like by
simply clicking and dragging now with
all of these options you don't have to
click and drag you can hover over it and
start typing so if I press find and then
enter it will stretch that out five
times or if I press Tab and go 10 it
will lift that sphere 10 meters in to
the air so if you don't want to tab
through it you can easily do it in that
method as well the last thing I'll add
before I wrap this video up entirely is
your Navigator down the bottom this is
going to lead us into the second video
of how we can import a project into twin
motion now I'm going to be giving away
100 free one of my twin motion files
which has a fully modeled Building
inside so make sure you join us in the
next video to be able to get that
download link down the bottom you have
your import which again tap the plus
button to import your materials your
objects your plants whatever you wanted
through that setting you have your
materials in Greater detail so basically
your full materials library of what is
in your project or what you've placed in
your project you can populate which
activates on the right hand side which
has to do with our landscaping and
environment I'll dive into that as well
later you have your media which is where
you'll create stunning photorealistic
compositions either through photography
videography Panorama VR or any of the
available options in Twin motion you can
do each of those by simply tapping
across any of these icons hitting the
plus button and Away you go last but not
least your export button which will be
the final thing we discuss in this
tutorial welcome back to part two where
we're going to dive straight in to the
nitty-gritty and I'm going to give you
guys a gift so first of all let's start
by showcasing what that gift is if we
hit the import button go to open you're
going to be able to download this twin
motion tutorial SketchUp file if if we
open that up keep all of our settings
exactly the same as you see them on the
screen right now and press import
it's going to process all of that data
and bring in our beautiful house that
we're going to be modeling and playing
with now I'm going to leave a Dropbox
link to this project right here directly
below glow plants in the description so
go download this and keep following on
with tutorial basically once you've done
that what we're going to do is we're
going to select the starting ground like
we learned last time we'll select the
top arrow and just drag that starting
ground lower until it fully disappears
from our entire project changing our
speed across so we can fly a little bit
quicker because this project got bigger
we don't need this starting base anymore
so I'm simply going to select the
starting base and hit delete if you fly
around to check out this beautiful house
it is a unique design cancel a room
across the cascading land over the ocean
which would be somewhere over here we'll
dive into that later but in today's
tutorial we are talking about the
materiality of this house how we can
make it look absolutely stunning best
practice would be to actually create the
hdri sky first and select what you want
this environment to look like so then
that way we don't have to go back and
actually change our materials to the sky
so before we dive into materials I will
be diving into hdri Skies first thing
you want to do is simply select your
skies and go into Skies once more
after that your choice you can pick any
of the Skies available to you there's
hundreds and hundreds of options
generally I like a morning and afternoon
sun and generally like it to be either
cloudy or clear I like a darker grayer
Sky to really pop the actual building
out a little bit more and when you shift
through them the little picture appears
on the right hand side and you see how
it affects glass solid and reflective
materials so each one will change the
color of your actual project hence why I
personally recommend it is important to
pick your hdri Sky first now for ease of
use let's simply go back let's go to an
overcast Sky let's pick Sky 10 and all
we need to do is Click left click once
drag it onto your sky and drop it into
your project that will automatically
change adjust and make the scene
significantly nicer now if you wanted to
adjust the actual orientation of that
sky where the Shadows are cast in the
building meaning you'd see the ambience
panel on the right hand side change
and all you'd need to do was scroll down
to hdri Sky and adjust your rotation
panel so however you wanted those
Shadows to be cast on your building you
could simply adjust the rotation for me
personally I'm not too fast I'm not too
bothered it's more about creating the
actual environment getting those colors
right to begin with so let's label that
and not worry about it that will come to
all of that in another video what we
want to do is come to our materials
palette and we want to go through each
step one by one and really fine tune
these things so let's get started with
glass being the very first material on
our list if we select glass we're going
to have 100 different options completely
up to us which one we choose do I want
clear glass so I can drag drop that
directly into my project and see into my
house from a distance potentially but at
the same time I really like a slight
reflective glass because that way when
you had some clouds into the photos and
into the renders you can see the
reflection of whatever's on the other
side personally I like that I really
enjoy a reflective glance now to make
this glass really stand out we want to
go through a reflective glass material
palette on the right hand side every
single material is going to have
something similar so I'll explain in
detail for glass and then you'll get the
general gist of it for everything else
first of all you have your 3D sphere
that showcases how that object would
actually look in reality you can change
it to standard glass or you can go to
color glass which loses its transparency
completely down below you're going to
have the tint so if I select the tint
you're going to have a Color Picker open
up this Color Picker can occasionally
get hidden behind the project so if at
any point in time you cannot click on
anything twin motion seems like it's
broken or that it's frozen just move
your window around so you can find this
Color Picker but bye the Color Picker
very self-explanatory drag it round
change it adjust it if you want red dark
glass you can have that tinted red glass
absolutely disgusting each to their own
and twin motion allows you to do
whatever you want potentially you might
want black dark or even frosted glass
you can change that slightly there so
you get nice black glass you can open up
the details panel and adjust the sliders
as you would in Lightroom but for now
I'm going to keep that closed opacity is
going to be exactly what you'd expect it
to be it's the opacity of the
transparency within the glass and just
like tint you have a few more little
details below you can invert the mask
use opacity map get really intricate and
really detailed with your actual objects
but for now we'll keep it relatively
basic we won't overwhelm you at this
point in time continuing to move down if
we had a pattern on our glass so let's
change it to this crazy floral sticker
that I hope nobody puts on an entire
facade of a building like this you can
adjust the rotation along with the
slider and it will adjust that pattern's
rotation you can also adjust the scale
here if you wanted it to be bigger or
smaller this is applicable all but
obviously a lot easier to understand and
comprehend with a pattern shown on top
if you open up the details panel you can
get a bit more control stretch it on the
x-axis stretch it on the y-axis only
offset left and right if you're trying
to align patterns together and if you're
trying to make patterns move you can
adjust them like that so they have some
sort of speed to them in a direction
again you wouldn't have that for a
static but the option is available to
you if you wanted to to be a mirror see
if we drag and drop mirror we'll go back
to your original reflective glass up top
left it doesn't matter how many changes
you make to this you can always come
back and drag and drop the original back
in that's always best to just go through
and play with all of these settings to
see how they infect the project how they
affect the material and what can be done
to make the details look even better for
me personally Glass isn't too bad it's
one of those objects that's pretty
decent from the get-go so I'm happy to
leave it as just reflective glass for
the time being
moving back into our materials we can
now dive into our Metals for me
personally in this instance the window
frames would be some fall of metal they
could be a brushed aluminum maybe matte
Chrome or even a habit copper finish
pending what we were looking for being
on the coast it might even be galvanized
steel so if I wanted it to be drag drop
let that go on the window frame now I
definitely don't want it to be
galvanized steel let's scroll back up
let's grab our matte Chrome drag and
drop that over our aluminum frames
scroll back up to our color select the
color palette and then adjust so simply
dragging down is going to change that
from a gray to Black and pressing OK up
close you can see there's not much going
on here it's relatively rough it's not
too smooth it's pretty much in the
middle because roughness is at 50. so if
I drag it back down to zero we'll get
quite a bit of shine quite a bit of
reflection on these window frames it's
up to you if that's what you want or if
you'd actually like it to be a little
bit different so I could easily adjust
that back up and make it back in the
middle of 50. now there are a few
glitches in this model and I do
apologize for that however it was a
quick model to be able to give you guys
something free something that you can
actually learn twin motion with so
whenever you have glitches like this in
the model it basically means two
materials are overlapping if I select
that object right there it's probably
gonna let me move it ever so slightly so
if I pick that go minus 0.01 press OK
fly back in that is going to disappear
because my materials are no longer
mobile lapping now what you'll notice in
Twin motion with my window frames that
black color was automatically linked to
my roof in Twin motion any colors you
have in your base model so wherever
you've imported it from SketchUp
archicad whatever you're gonna have to
understand that it's going to link
colors together
so by having this window frame is black
and the roof is black any adjustments I
make to the window frame is
automatically going to change it to the
roof now because I've unclicked off that
window frame you might be thinking oh no
how do I come back to that well if you
come up to the top you're going to see
this eyedropper tool it's our material
pickup by simply dragging across
anything left clicking it's going to
open up that material that you're
looking for same with this matte Chrome
same as the roof so now if I were to
adjust this slider you'd see the roof
change in the line with my window frames
pressing cancel it will change that back
to how I want it to be and we can
continue working through this design and
the materials the concrete on the
outside is shown as a concrete panel but
it really wouldn't be it'd most likely
be some sort of smooth concreted finish
it wouldn't have the concrete panel
lines or not to this extent
so if we come back to our main library
and come into Mega scans this time for a
different material we'll go into
surfaces and we're going to scroll until
we find concrete on the left hand side
Mega scans has so many more options for
us so we can go through these and try
and find the best thing for what we're
trying to articulate if we start with
the slab tool we can scroll through all
the options and see if there's anything
that we really like in this scenario a
cast in situ concrete like this could be
quite nice and I say could because every
material is slightly different so if we
hit that little download Arrow we can
let it download to our computer right
click drag it across before letting go
what you'll notice is all Mega scans
materials and objects will kind of come
in white and pause it's because they're
downloading into your system now for the
first time so now if I Let Go object
creation will happen and we'll see some
sort of form work now that rotation
would become very important in this
scenario because we need to rotate it so
it aligns perfectly with this but now I
have all sorts of problems because my
model is in a variety of different
angles so that formboard concrete
without going back into the original
model just will insert this project so
if we come back out let's go into smooth
and try to find a beautiful concrete
let's download this concrete floor
and potentially also a few others let's
go smooth concrete wall
concrete sidewalk just download a few to
test out and see what the best options
are for us so let's start with concrete
sidewalk drag drop release grungy it's a
bit grainy but it's a lot of bad
concrete color per se so I'm going to
leave this one as potential maybe as we
scroll through the other options the
smooth concrete is definitely to Bland
and too boring for me but what I could
do is increase some grunge which is
basically aging weathering in the actual
material which would give it a bit more
of the look I'm looking for so that
actually is quite nice in my opinion for
this model
I could then also turn down the
lumiosity which would make it a little
bit darker or a little bit lighter a
little bit more glowing zooming back out
we could potentially see how that
building looks from afar now obviously
it would be amazing to get rid of this
garage move it somewhere else in this
model it just didn't work anywhere else
in this design however if you wanted to
delete it you could go through one by
one and just start tapping the delete
button until eventually you got
somewhere and deleted enough of it that
you were happy with now I'll undo all
that because I kind of want to keep the
garage for the purposes of argument and
for this tutorial so we'll keep that
there but you can delete it all if you
so choose and want to make this even
more powerful of an architectural
statement now for the time being again
I'm relatively happy with this concrete
and I can adjust it continuously as we
move on or I could easily go back to my
sidewalk reduce my scale or increase my
scale to make it something a little bit
different it's probably a little bit too
busy for the sidewalk so I'm going to
keep it as that smooth concrete increase
the grunge
adjust my settings ever so slightly and
there we go now we have a concrete
fascia design that basically will create
an absolute stunning render from almost
any angle looking at it if we wanted to
fly into our house we could simply hit
that eye again go to our pedestrian mode
and it would drop us into pedestrian
mode we can't actually walk through
solid objects anymore which is really
frustrating so pedestrian mode unless
you've got everything set up properly
it's not going to work for you but you
will have a perfectly accessible
pedestrian so if we jump back into drone
mode fly into our house
now change back into pedestrian mode
we can walk around our house freely
maybe let's reduce our speed back to
three or four so that we can walk around
our house bump into all walls we can't
make it through the doors until we go
back to drone mode but we can see what's
going on in this main space as if we
actually lived here and if you wanted to
mess with the materials on the inside
you could very much do so like this
stone for example needs a little bit of
work needs a little bit of love so if we
go back to our Mega scan surfaces go
into our marble let's go polished marble
and see what kind of options we have in
stunning polished marble there is many
many options for us including this one's
quite similar to this Stone but maybe
it'll look significantly nicer simply
drag drop let go and there we go we have
a marble Stone top that is pretty much
seamless all the way across and it's a
very nice texture that we can adjust as
we see fit so let's say one a bit darker
a little bit lighter it's all there for
course to mess with play with and adjust
in case you wanted a nice pink Island
bench top you could create that in a
matter of seconds now I'll undo that I
just want to keep it pretty generic
pretty simple going back into drive mode
flying back out to the externals the
materials aren't just for the house
they're also for our environment as well
so let's go back to library let's go
back to materials and let's select
ground what we want to do before we dive
into actually any landscape design which
we'll get into another video we want to
give everything a bit of a base layer so
that we have it something to build on if
we go nature we're going to have a
variety of different Earths and dirts
and Sands and bits and bobs so for
instance I can grab grass 5 drag and
drop and now I have new grass at the
bottom of my house this sand down below
where Matt want it to be cracked ground
we might want it to be desert sand maybe
something from the beach we could have a
variety of different options to our
hearts content but for the time being
let's just go some deserts and let's
drop that in see what that looks like
from a low angle like this
you're gonna see the beautiful Peaks and
valleys of the desert sand which we
again adjust or decrease in scale as we
see fit for the purpose of the render
sand isn't isn't one of those things
that has so many Peaks and valleys so
the Sun hits it in a magnitude of ways
and it's quite challenging to to pick
that with a 2d texture so if we increase
our grunge we're going to start seeing a
lot more darker patches a lot more
changes in the actual moisture so it
starts to look a little bit more real we
don't want it to look too dirty and dark
so maybe somewhere in the 50 we could
also slide our lumens down increase our
roughness so it's a very rough texture
now let's say we wanted to use this
material for the rest of the environment
we can simply select the material picker
select the material we want to use and
instead of dragging it from the palette
and trying to copy it over and over and
over again we could grab our desert sand
drag and drop it into the environment
and it'll replicate that identical
material for the rest now I don't
actually want that I believe the
background would be much nicer as some
sort of grass to vegetation maybe Mossy
ground to something a little bit darker
a little bit Greener would be lovely I
know I'm gonna have a series of trees
this is basically a forest behind this
project I'm easily just going to grab
Forest ground dirt maybe some
cobblestones or maybe even some ground
plant cover drag and drop it in increase
my scale and make sure from up close
that looks relatively decent now when it
comes time to increase and add all about
plants I can easily drop some beautiful
plants in there last but not least is
going to be our ground and our man-made
objects so for instance this road is the
wrong material for starters we want it
to be a nice little asphalt simply drag
and drop the asphalt in and it's done we
can adjust make it a bit darker make it
a bit dirtier and it looks a little bit
more realistic now generally speaking if
you're doing a very fine tuned render
you could go back into live really into
Mega scan surfaces scroll down to the
bottom to Asphalt find a rough asphalt
that was more appealing and potentially
you could have one with lines
automatically built in but because this
shapes and changes and meanders it isn't
just consistently one straight road if I
were to drag rough line markings it
would just be a very messy texture now
one thing I'll point out quickly is that
material linking so because I changed
this to that garden bed it's changed my
actual garden bed in here as well if I
go back to ground Back To Nature just
change that Forest covered it will be
more of an earth or a mulch type
material if we want to take it a step
further and actually get really deep
into custom materials well then we could
come down to the bottom here go to our
materials dock find a material that we
really really like let's say we like
this Forest ground but we want to find
something better online or create our
own texture
first of all what we need to do is right
click we want to duplicate and then we
want to re-name that material let's
rename it to Earth's tutorial and press
enter now if I select Earth tutorial we
can adjust things to make it even better
let's dive into the details if we drop
down that menu you'll see a textures
embedded image there's multiples on
multiples of different textured websites
out there on the internet so feel free
to use whatever you can find for the
better options you're going to have to
pay for them or you can try create your
custom ones through simple Googling for
the purpose of this let's jump into
Google search Earth seamless texture so
that your textures align without random
joins and funny objects and find
something that you like it can literally
be almost anything that's free so if you
also type in royalty free it'll give you
a few more images to select from but you
can comfortably know aren't going to be
copyrighted now for the purpose in this
there's an issue me grab any of these
this appears to be a royalty free image
I'm not going to dive into it too much
it does look like it's watermarked so I
wouldn't say it is actually free I would
say you'd have to pay for this one if
you're going to use it commercially so
let's pick this cracked Earth one for
just argument right click save to
downloads
close that go back to our twin motion
tutorial click on our texture and let's
go open in your downloads folder you're
going to find that material so simply
press open again
and you'll see that texture immediately
change on the 3D little Globe if we
wanted to drag and drop that over our
sand
and zoom in you can see
an incredible textured surface that
could be utilized however you want
increase the scale you'll see it Frac
and pit and change increase the grunge
it gets dirty filthy now it looks like
you're in the middle of the actual
desert so if there is an material that
you can find available to you online or
through the twin motion Library you can
always go ahead and make your own
welcome back team we are diving into
part three today with objects now twin
motion has a variety of different
objects so we're going to get right into
it again if you're joining us for the
first time and you're just seeing this
amazing model and thinking how do I get
my hands on it there is a link down
below completely free so you can grab it
and join along so let's talk about the
objects available to us directly in Twin
motion and then we'll move on to the
objects we can find on the internet as
well so first of all onto the left hand
side of the palette you're going to have
your objects if if you dive into objects
simply by clicking once you're going to
get a variety of different elements
we'll go through these one by one
because again this is a very thorough
course to make sure that you're an
absolute Pro so diving into home we're
going to have a variety of amazing
things to be able to Showcase this
better let's fly inside our house let's
turn on our little pedestrian mode so by
clicking the eye tapping our man going
pedestrian mode we are now at human
scale and we can't accidentally go
outside of our actual environment
now let's click on living room and see
what options we have a billion one
options again so so many options but
let's start with electronic appliances
nice TV directly above our fireplace
here in the center so let's click it
once click it onto where we want to did
it and then press escape to get rid of
it if the TV is too small we can select
our TV once hit the tab button slowly to
adjust through the different options
press tab again we get our three squares
with the fourth being in the center
which allows us to scale like we did
before if we want to drag that out to
1.3 drag that out make that TV bigger we
simply can or command Z command Z undoes
that we can simply hold and hover over
the center so it highlights all of the
cursors and go tap 1.5 enter and we have
a huge huge TV now we can also use any
of the intermediate spaces in between
these arrows to move them along that
axis as well so now we have this
stunning TV with a strange reflection of
the sky but we'll get to that a little
bit later of how we can get rid of that
horrendous Sky reflection because you
wouldn't have a scar reflecting off and
say they're there at all if we scroll
through our abundance of objects you'll
see a ton keep coming up and in Twin
motion they've recently added even more
fantastic items that you can simply
download directly into twin motion so if
you didn't like that TV that was on the
wall where you could pick another one of
these TVs or potentially maybe you
wanted to download a tablet so let's
select that little download Arrow let
the tablet download for a few seconds
click on the tablet once
hover over where we want it to be
created click once again
and it will create that tablet on the
side so now I can press Escape Zoom to
my tablet click on it adjust it to where
I want it to be so let's say one of the
kids has accidentally left it just on
the side it could get bumped it could
get knocked but they've left it there
and we're showcasing it in our render if
we come back across we're going to see a
variety of additional objects available
to us as well so if we wanted to go into
sofas we could introduce a sofa couch
directly in front of us however
personally I hate every single one of
these objects in Twin motion as a sofa
they're also generic they're also boring
and they're incredibly incredibly cheap
so we could continue to go through each
and every single one of these look at
all the kids toys you know have some fun
find some entertainment systems put a
pool table in if we wanted to there is
actually a designated space over here
for a pool table so we would definitely
be putting one of these in what kind of
pool table should we put in I personally
don't love any of them but this one is
the best because it's got a black top so
let's download this pool table wait a
few seconds for it to download click
once click again to create the object
and position it exactly where we want it
to go that looks like it's definitely
not in the center of the room the center
is roughly where this window is and
aligned with the fire pit so that's
roughly where the center and the pool
table would go if we were to have one
and you'd be able to see people playing
a lovely game pool behind now we've
gotten sidetracked from the main points
here we want to come all the way back to
our main library we want to talk about
the second available option in Twin
motion if you come down to sketchfab and
select sketchfab once again you're going
to have an abundance of categories to
work your way through and it will drive
you nuts but if we want to Simply go on
furniture and home select it once you'll
see I've downloaded a ton of different
objects in the past and they're
automatically saved to my twin motion so
because I've used all of these in the
past they're immediately there I don't
have to download them again I don't have
to search for them they just come up as
first which is really really good and
really helpful now let's say I was
looking for a sofa I was looking for a
couch you could also just simply type in
sofa up the top let it do its thing see
what it can find and it will show you a
million and one different examples with
sofas basically anything that anybody
has ever created on sketchfab is
available to download for free which is
phenomenal it means you can find sofas
from Ikea you can find sofas from your
favorite designer you can basically find
anything under the sun that's available
if you search hard enough and that's the
big if because it takes a long time to
go through all of these options so if we
undo that and let's drag and drop one of
these sofas that I've used in the past
let's grab this sofa here drop it in the
middle in the front of that TV and then
I'm simply just gonna duplicate it
across so by pressing tab I can then
hover over the Green Arrow because I
want to shift it to the left hold shift
while clicking and dragging letting go
and it will produce a copy a dialog box
if you create an instance copy that
means anything that you do to the right
hand so far or the original so far is
immediately going to translate to the
copy that you've made this works vice
versa for both and basically everything
that uses copy function for if you
select copy they will work independently
of each other which makes life super
easy but also challenging so make sure
you're selecting the right instance or
copy every single time and paying
attention this sofa needs to be the same
so let's go instance let's press OK
let's rotate it 180 degrees
and then let's simply adjust this sofa
back into the other one move it across a
little bit so we have this unique
double-sided sofa by holding command and
clicking on the second couch I can
select them both at the same time and
move them wherever I want to
go back to my main sketch Fab and type
in coffee table
you can type in multiple words and it
will search them as individual words so
you may have some weird strange things
pop up like this car but otherwise you
should generally get most of what you're
looking for I have no idea what this
house would look like inside I haven't
really thought about it too much so
let's simply just download any of these
tables here maybe this glass table here
would be quite lovely that has happened
during this tutorial because it's a
prime example of a few of the glitches
inside twin motion I've pressed the
download button but nothing is happening
it's only 524 kilowatts so it should
have downloaded in a heartbeat but it's
basically glitched I can't download it I
can't pause it I really can't do
anything unfortunately at the moment I
don't have a workaround for anybody
which means you have to Simply go find
another coffee table that you like
download it and use that one
so let's try it download this one as an
alternative
and you'll see it started downloading as
well as provide the pause option whereas
if I scroll back up that one hasn't
moved at all now this takes me to my
third and final library inside twin
motion obviously you have your cars and
you use the library and characters
so if you go into characters you can
drag and drop any of the people into
your scenes if you go into Vehicles you
can drag and drop any of the cars into
your scenes similar in sketchfab you
have vehicles and you have characters
and creatures so you can drag and drop
very specific high-end cars into the
project as well you just simply search
them and go ahead and download them
however you also have the mega scans
library now the mega scans 3D assets are
actually scanned objects from The Real
World as an example let's go into
interior let's go into furniture and
let's go table you'll see a number of
different tables have come up and
available to us in theory Mega scans is
all about realistic high quality objects
from The Real World scanned in to the
digital world they're basically creating
digital twins of everything available
therefore objects will be of
significantly greater quality and detail
well but they're not going to have too
many options and a lot of them are going
to be just so strange that you're not
going to want to use them as an example
let's drop this wooden table in go back
to our drone mode so we can inspect it
quite closely and you'll see that it is
an extremely well detailed table it
isn't really like it's been modeled
because there's so many strange little
curves undulations changes in the
material and that's because it has been
3D scanned which is incredible that is
such a cool thing that you can do
nowadays you can take your iPhone you
can scan any material and you can
actually develop it yourself into twin
motion if you're using the right apps
but let's delete that table go back to
some of our other options maybe we want
the fireplace maybe there's something
amazing that we can put in if you're in
an old Heritage building these would be
incredible but for the purpose of this
not so much you can also find things
like details in extremely intricate wall
panels wall detailing very very historic
and exquisitely crafted items then
unfortunately we no longer do but this
is where you can find them inside the
mega scans Library moving on outside of
twin motion now if we come across to our
actual browser whatever you're using
Safari Chrome it doesn't matter it's
literally on the internet you're gonna
have a variety of different places you
can find some awesome stuff to add into
your project of course you're going to
be able to find things from Globe plants
which is the series sponsor for this
twin motion tutorial and full course so
please do check them out there is a link
in the description down below and if you
wanted to download any extremely high
quality plans you could find it right
here on Globe plants for example this
fiddle leaf tree right here is
absolutely stunning the details are
Exquisite and to be honest it's
basically in every Australian's house so
it is almost a staple for any anybody in
Australia creating 30 renders we can
dive into 3D Sky 3D sky to the best of
my knowledge it used to be a Russian
website that's kind of been converted
into 3dsguide.org
but it is an incredible resource with
some amazing high quality 3D models
the downside is not everything is free
and you can only get three free
downloads per 24 hours so if I want to
decide search for dining table first of
all I could spell it right with one n
and you see there's some incredible
stuff things that you see in those high
quality renders that people are charging
hundreds of thousands of dollars for and
if you download one of these once off
you can have it forever I like to Simply
hit the little free tab scroll down and
select fbx because twin motion works the
best with fbx files and then try and
find a table that I like you can
literally pick anything that you like
and download it relatively quickly and
free of charge I don't love any of these
tables so I'm not even going to try it
find something that's amazing let's
simply scroll up pick this table here
and you're gonna have to sign in or
create an account so I'm going to sign
in and then I'm going to hit the free
download button for me it's downloaded
as a raw file so all I need to do double
click it'll open up
what you'll notice in this unarchiving
screen here that I've dragged across the
file name is like I mentioned before
you've got some Russian letters because
it's probably a Russian website but it
also straight up lied to us it said
there'd be an fbx file and it's only
providing us a 3ds Max and an obj file
we can still use the obj file so we can
definitely export that out but
unfortunately we didn't get our xbf file
so now that we've exported all of these
items we can come back into twin motion
we can dive down into our import file
press the plus button come across to
geometry and go open find the table in
your downloads file and you'll see only
the obj file is active so let's click on
that let's open it up and import on the
right hand side on the scene finder if
you scroll across the bottom select
table and pan around until you see the
main cursor you can hover over this
yellow sphere in the middle drag and
drop it roughly in front of you tab
across and scale the object accordingly
the problem with obj's in Twin motion is
first of all they import the wrong way
they import the wrong size so you have
to do quite a lot of work to make them
actually appear as they need to for
personally what I do is I delete that
table I would go back to 3D Sky use
another one of my free downloads let's
try this one download it go through that
same process
find the fbx file this time open that up
and import it into our project now that
table will reappear it'll be a much
better size it is the correct scale the
correct format rotate it around once
again unfortunately those textures
didn't come across exactly as we need
them to be it's mainly the timber that
didn't come into play so we'll select
those wood legs go texture go open
import the wood and there we go now we
have our wooden table exactly as
pictured but not perfect so
unfortunately when you're playing with
free 3D models you don't get the best of
it the best you kind of have to work
around it make it work but otherwise
when you're playing with paid objects it
is so much easier if you wanted to go
through work your way through all of
these rooms obviously there's a couple
bedrooms in here another bedroom a
master suite with some Cabinetry
potentially an additional
gymnasium in the rear your bathroom all
sorts of stuff happening in this model
you can go ahead add it all in so as one
final example if we were to go to
sketchbab we were to go back into our
furniture we can drag and drop this high
quality bed into our project so that it
appears cantilevering off this
absolutely stunning bedroom at the edge
what's going on team we are back with
part four and today we are talking about
a landscaping and the environment of
course with globe plans being the
official response of this series we are
going to be using a lot of globe plants
from our pre-downloaded glow plants
library now we'll talk about all of
these amazing things as we work through
however I want to get started with the
actual environment and potentially
setting up our first render scene so
when we set up our environment I like to
set up my first scene let's come down to
the bottom let's go to media and click
click the first plus button this is just
a generic step to set everything up and
work our way through what I really want
to do is make sure all these settings
are right before going on and making my
next image so let's get started by
jumping all the way across the image
changing it from Full HD across to 8K if
your computer supports high resolution
bump it up as high as you possibly can
now we can do tiled rendering and we can
also do a view set but for the purpose
of this I'm just going to Simply leave
it off
next we're going to jump to our camera
and we're going to set up our very first
scene for me personally I almost want it
to look like we're standing at the
bottom of the ocean we're standing at
the heel looking up at this fantastic
house and we want to be standing maybe
somewhere over here from an angle
somewhere different you know have a few
different angles set up so potentially
this might be one shot another one might
be over here
so I'm going to come back all the way to
the front of the house
and I'm going to slide my focal length
back and forward until I'm relatively
happy
for me I think anywhere from a 35
millimeter would look quite nice for the
depth of this image at the same time
that means I need to push quite far back
in this scene to make sure this whole
house still fits if I wanted to continue
maybe make it a hundred mil that means
I'd once again have to fly out quite far
back to be able to fit everything in
this scene now 100 Mil in this scenario
isn't exactly great so we're going to
dive back to 35 millimeters press OK fly
until we're happy with that scene so I'm
going to put my scene somewhere just
about here
and then I'm going to hover over my
image one and refresh by refreshing that
is going to lock in our position and
while we move around if we double click
back on image one it'll go back to that
image very rapidly while we're on camera
we can dive into a couple additional
features so first of all we have a depth
of field because this is a relatively
far distant shot we don't really need to
worry about depth of field because we're
not in close proximity to something
however if we wanted to pick a focal
point we could click focal point and
dive to that space so everything in the
foreground would be nice and blurred out
and be focusing on the house itself
otherwise you can click all the way at
the back to the furthest point so it is
selecting that if we wanted to change
the aperture as well to let in more or
less light we could and we could also
change the bokeh shape so if you look
down the bottom you'll see that the blur
slightly changes next we can dive into
camera effect and we have our standard
beginning vignetting is basically the
camera focusing in on itself and more
black or white coming in around the
edges so the higher it goes up the more
it kind of focuses the eye into the
center by fading away the distance I
don't personally like it too much we
don't need it in this case if you want
to adjust a little bit to really focus
your eyes to the center of this project
it could but because we're trying to
focus the eye all the way as far as we
possibly can I don't really need it para
realism is something I have to say
slowly because it was very hard to say
time and time again in quick succession
but basically what it does is it
emphasizes the vertical lines of the
camera angle cool so if you're doing a
skyscraper or something like that this
is when this becomes important near
clipping in this instance is not
applicable because we're so far back so
we'll skip over that one composition
layouts we have our grid and if we
wanted to use the rule of thirds this is
how you get your grid lines set up so in
this instance we could come up a little
bit put the house in the middle of the
composition and then refresh our scene
so we're permanently saved there if you
want to change the grid lines from a to
a different grid you can but composition
rule thirds is the best way to go now
we've gone through environment we've
gone through camera we can go through
render as well and Global illumination
is something that we can play with turn
it on and off basically it allows the
sun Reflections throughout the project
if you're having a lot of glitches come
out in your video exports simply turn
that off and it will get rid of that
glitch usually it means your computer
isn't powerful enough to be able to do
anything with global illumination if we
adjust these sliders ever so slightly we
can see how our shadows of play effect
on the building itself so adjusting them
more or less either provides more of a
shadow or less of a shadow for me I'm
happy to leave it where it was 150 and
0.4 because we're not playing with too
many shadows in this instance a 400
meter Shadow is something I will like to
play with because it is either no
Shadows at all and it plays a very harsh
Shadow or it feathers it a little bit
more I like to have my Shadows quite
nicely feathered because as we start
adding trees you'll see that context
change
the shadow bias as well is going to play
into effect on all of the Contours so if
you don't want as many Shadows on the
Contours you increase the shadow bias if
you want a little bit more you decrease
that bias and last but not least is the
reflection on the glass turn it on and
off however you wish but usually
Reflections are a great thing to turn on
now we could also dive into the effects
panel but I personally think the more
you play with this the less you're going
to have a quality render that's
consistent time and time again so we're
going to leave effects completely off
but same principles you can go through
slide and adjust as you see fit the clay
render is something that's fun to play
with as well so if we were changing that
to a white clay render we could untick
our glass so that the actual glass comes
into play and and then we could keep
unticking things as we see fit but again
clay render not something we're going to
be talking about in this beginner's
tutorial now like I promised we are
going to dive deep into this and
environment to make sure our scene is
perfectly set up before we start placing
these beautiful trees and Landscaping
into the actual scene so let's scroll
down to the bottom and start with our
ocean first of all I want to enable the
ocean it's going to be way too high in
the project but that's okay we're simply
going to slide that slider down ever so
slightly and try get that scene to align
where we want it to be unfortunately the
way I've designed it the Contours aren't
working too well with the natural ocean
so we're not going to use the natural
ocean instead I'm going to bake it in
this image so let's turn the ocean off
let's come back into our library let's
go into objects we're going to go to
water and we're simply going to select a
water Cube now I'm going to drop this
watercube roughly here fly around rotate
it as I need it to be increase the size
significantly by simply dragging the
sliders across coming back to my scene
and adjusting further until it's perfect
aligned with where I want it to be now
the good thing is when I select this
ocean I can change it from pull one pull
two and pull three so I think pull two
looks quite nice in this scenario next
we want to play with our hdri Sky now
I'm aware that we introduced one hdri
sky before but what we actually want to
do is adjust and fine tune to make this
look incredible so let's break it down
first of all we want to rotate until we
find the perfect and optimal Shadows for
this project I have it set straight on
zero but if we let it rotate around
we can see the Shadows being cast over
the entire house as well as the
intensity at four so what I want to do
is probably leave it at zero because it
works in this instance but I want to
play with the intensity ever so slightly
the more I lower the intensity the
darker the scene gets so at 1.5 I quite
like that it's nice and dark and Moody
now what we're going to do is scroll
back up to the top go to our details and
untick auto exposure immediately it's
going to go dark because obviously your
exposure is gone we want to manually
adjust our exposure so simply sliding
this exposure slider up ever so slightly
until we're perfectly happy with the
environment so at about 3.83 I'm okay
with this exposure at the same time we
have our details panel below that's
opened up that lets us go through
individual elements first of all our
ambient is going to indicate all of the
glare that we have from our project so
sliding these sliders down you'll see
the ambient brightness increase and
decrease on the model because we're
looking at the glass predominantly in
this scene I don't mind having the
ambience a little bit higher maybe about
1.3 the white balance is of course
talking about the sun and the color the
sun gives off so slide it all the way up
a lot more yellow slide it down it's a
lot more blue in this environment I want
it to be a little bit warmer I'd be out
at the beach so six eight seven thousand
is about right the sun reflection and
the size as well as the intensity is
something we can play with so if we
Slide the sun scales up you'll see that
the actual sun is brighter or darker
very simple stuff nothing too crazy just
basically go through these until you're
happy with the environment of how it
looks so by turning the sun reflection
down I'm not bouncing my sunlight off as
much which gives us those nice and dark
Rich Contours and contrast in this model
but yet by having the Sun bright it
still gives us enough richness and color
overall now that we've adjusted all of
those scenes we can go back into our
hgri sky and play with our intensity one
last time so we just adjust the
intensity of the sky to match our
environment that we've set up in the
camera angles
now what you'll notice is at the very
top of this building the Shadows are
being cast but at the same time the
sun's kind of coming through so we want
to come back across to our path tracing
and our rendering section in the middle
here of the camera
and we want to adjust our shadows and
our shadow bias
so by lowering our shadow bias
and adjusting our shadows to a little
bit lower we now
have our shadows being portrayed exactly
as they would be in real life now at the
same time it started bucketing outside
here so apologize if you can hear some
rain in the background we've got some
crazy weather here in Australia at the
moment nothing like this render is at
all so we have this beautiful
picturesque scene we've set it up we've
got the global illuminization on we've
set up our environment we know what it's
going to look like
we can always come back to this image
without having to redo any of these
settings and if we wanted to do a second
image well we simply fly across find the
camera position we want and then hit the
plus button again so in this scenario
maybe we wanted something over here
overlooking from the side hit the plus
button and make sure that our water is
extended far enough and there we go now
we have two camera angles two renders
set up very quickly very rapidly reusing
those angles what I will point out if
you fly around to the back side you will
have to adjust most of these settings to
fine tune it again I always like to set
up one render and one scene so by
sticking to image one we can work
through our landscaping design slowly
but with precision and detail first
let's get started with some basic stuff
we want to populate the environment so
if we come down to the bottom and hit
populate then we go to foliage and we go
paint
I want to come across to my grass and
flowers and select one of my grass to
start painting this actual building so
for me I don't mind most of these
grasses they're all quite okay Globe
plans has some great ones as well I
haven't purchased any of them so that's
why I'm not using glow plants grass for
this instance I'm simply going to select
long brass 2 drag drop let that come in
now I'm going to click on Long Grass to
and increase my density to 100 meaning
when I paint everywhere I paint grass is
going to come up
I'm then going to click on my paint
brush tool and decrease my size two
meters so I can get a decent bit of
control if I zoom in and fly in to this
section you see that I can start
painting
effortlessly and it will paint the grass
quite well now obviously I've got my
depth of field on hence why everything's
so blurry when I'm here so let's quit
Media mode and you'll see
not blurry anymore
if you accidentally paint a wall or
something you don't like you can select
the Eraser tool and just unpaint that
section there so it's simple as that
come back to your paintbrush lower it to
one so you can get a lot more control
next to the building
and then what you want to do is
basically go through the rest of this
project add grass to its entirety
and I won't boil with you with that so
I'll skip ahead and you'll see all of
this grass beautifully painted in before
I jump ahead of course there is a
quicker way to do this but the results
aren't as pristine and they aren't as
nice so we come back to populate we go
scatter we can drop our long grass in
select long grass go 100 and click a
scatter tool and then click on the grass
it will automatically scatter green
grass everywhere across that material I
can obviously click multiple times to
keep it scattered and keep it going
so that's a multiple press
but even if I zoom in here you'll see
the difference is actually quite visible
and not as neat so I like to paint my
grass in personally I like to take the
time it's a little bit soothing a little
bit relaxing
if you simply just click on that grass
you can immediately go back to that
paintbrush and continue painting in that
environment
and there we go now I've painted in all
of my grass and you can see it come up
with this orange because I've got my
distance Marker set if I double click on
image one it will all disappear and
that's for a good reason in fact I'll
have to edit preferences and then come
to Grass fading you'll see I have it
medium if I want to see more of the
grass I can select far and press OK and
some of that grass will come in to play
again now the reason I don't is
obviously it uses more computing power
to display more of the vegetation so
back to edit back to medium for me and
I'm happy simply remembering that my
grass is there now we want to go in and
start adding some of our beautiful trees
and our accessories so let's go back to
library and if you don't have any of the
globe plans features first of all you
can grab it from the description below
there's some amazing selections of trees
from all around the world so feel free
to grab a bundle and install it directly
into user Library if you've never
downloaded a globe plants bundle before
or even an individual plant package it's
very simple to install simply download
it go to your documents folder in your
computer find twin motion 2023.1 or
whichever twin motion version you're
using double click on it double click on
user library and copy and paste the file
you've downloaded from Globe plants
directly into your user Library that's
it if you've got twin motion open close
it refresh it start it again and you'll
see the user Library appear however all
you have to do is seriously just copy
and paste that into user library and
then inside twin motion you can go there
click on Globe plants and have your
folder structure exactly as you set it
up it's not very hard at all and it's
definitely the easiest way to import
some amazing vegetation now what I want
to do is use some low poly trees in the
background up the top of this building
behind the actual environment I want to
create some sort of forest some sort of
bush land so I'm going to go through an
individual actually click into a number
of different trees so to do that I'm
simply going to select a few of my blue
plants trees drop them in and then just
individually scatter them around exactly
where I want them to be so because they
come in as groups you can select each
individual Magnolia drag it across
select a different one drag it where you
need it to be and continue that method
if you wanted to create individual trees
instead of having them in bundles you
can easily right click on that magnolia
tree and go add to user library and
you'll just have that individual
magnolia tree available to you that way
if you wanted to go through and paint a
series of trees you could quite easily
do that without having to manually
position them and manually move them
what I find about manually positioning
the trees is you get a lot more control
and a much nicer much more detailed
environment once you've added plenty of
trees in the background to start
creating your actual Forest we can go
back to populate we can go back to
paints and we can use some of the bushes
available now again you can either use
the globe plants Library using some of
the low poly because they're in the
background and we don't want to Overkill
our project we only want to use the high
poly in the specific areas
or we could also go to our vegetation
and go to our bushes and drag and drop a
bass Bush because it is in the
background let's select all of our globe
plants on the right hand side turn them
off quickly so we can do this a little
bit easier what I've done is made my
life hard so I'm going to erase all of
these extra bass bushes that I've made
gonna get my paintbrush simply paint
across the entire bottom length of this
forest and increase the density of that
so now we have a ton of bass bushes
turning back on our trees going back
down below to our image one we can see
those beautiful trees have come into
play and then we can focus on our
foreground so coming back into Library
let's go into objects let's go into
vegetation and let's go rocks I want to
drop a couple of rocks into this
environment just basically as fillers
into the land something a little bit
different so it's not just grass and
sand this way the Rocks actually add a
little bit of texture and something that
we can utilize in our landscape design
now next we're going to go back into our
user Library we're going to go into
Globe plans and we're going to go into
high poly and you're going to see the
quality difference between these low
pulley trees in the background and the
high poly glow plants so let's go into
one of these and find something stunning
there's some beautiful shrubs and bushes
available but what I'm looking for is a
grass tree so I've got a number of grass
trees available to me from Globe plants
and they're incredibly incredibly
detailed so if I zoom into this garage
tree you'll see the Exquisite detail all
the way to the finer flowers growing at
the very top and even the bark itself
these grass trees absolutely stunning
and by far an extremely Australian tree
that you'll basically only find here in
Australia don't quote me on that I'm not
a landscape expert but I do know they
grow very very well here so what I'll do
is scatter a few of these beautiful
grass trees around and then continue to
add some high poly plants now I've
included this tree right here which I
only really want the largest one so what
I'm going to do is select one of the
trees drag it all the way across at the
back of my building introduce it into
the environment then I can select the
remaining trees and simply delete them
because I don't need them for now I do
want to define the delineation and the
difference between the house the beach
in the land so what I'm going to do is
simply grab some more glow plants trees
and basically articulate this clear
delineation line now I've gone ahead and
added quite a bit of high poly Global
plans to this project and I must warn
you if you do have a slow computer
or you just don't have one that can
perform overly well you may need to come
back into preferences go to Quality and
reduce your quality to be able to speed
your computer back up because you're
adding thousands and thousands of little
polygons into your project and it just
won't be able to perform so even with an
M1 Ultra tube set with all of these tiny
tiny high quality polygon lines there's
just too much going on however there is
an exceptional view right here that
could be created by this incredible
cantilever with these Globe plants
images so if I so if I simply go back
into image 2 fly back in to that perfect
angle of that stunning cantilever of the
master bedroom overlooking the ocean
roughly line up my line where I want it
to be create a new image go to my camera
pick my new focal point being the master
bedroom furthest point exit that out and
refresh my scene we'll see all these
stunning Globe plants bokeh whilst the
distance is nice and crisp we can see a
little bit of water coming there in the
background and we don't have any
environment so we'd have to go through
and add a few more trees to the
background of this environment to really
give this render right here some
absolute life and flavor
so I'll quit Media mode copy and paste a
few of these trees over here and there
we go I've introduced a few more trees
into the environment personally I
actually don't think we need any bokeh
any depth of field in this so I'm going
to turn the depth of the field off and
refresh my scene so now we have the
detail of all of these beautiful glow
plants right here at the front and
because I haven't showcased them enough
I just want to fly in with a little bit
more texture a little bit more depth so
you can see the detail in these high
poly images now I've added some bushes
I've added some shrubs to delineate some
flowers some wild flowers and everything
is looking absolutely stunning obviously
in a spring collection because that is
when trees look the best like look at
the detail and quality of this plant in
front of me again I'm not a landscaper I
don't know an exceptional amount about
the specific plants and the details but
I do know that these are the highest
quality 3D plants money can buy on the
internet right now now if we quit our
Media mode once more and fly back into
our environment we need to be able to
get in and out of this house it's a
number of ways we can do that and I
actually want to create my own Stepping
Stones so let's go back to library let's
go objects and let's go primitive
actually want to use a one by one meter
box drag and drop that into our
environment then I want to adjust it
ever so slightly and tap my way through
until I get little concrete pavers of
approximately the right size that I'm
happy with so for me that's a half
decent concrete paver I can place it
where I need to be and simply rotate it
until I'm happy if I wanted to increase
the height so it's higher and sits away
from the grass I can go back into my
library go into my materials pick my
concrete and drag my concrete base onto
those steps next what I'd have to do is
duplicate a number of these steps all
the way
to the actual front door Now by holding
shift and duplicating I can just change
that number let's go five and it will
automatically make me five steps quickly
going forward and I can make maybe one
or two more here so that now I can begin
turning up this hill and if I wanted to
I could do it in a very linear pattern
or I can simply let the Contours of the
land Define the pattern of these
Stepping Stones I don't mind allowing
the Contours to define the pattern of
the stepping stone I'm actually quite
okay with it so I'm simply going to
continue one by one creating this
Meandering path to the actual home and
now that I've reached approximately this
front sliding door I believe there's a
sliding door here and a sliding door
over here as well I can either fine tune
some of these steps so they're closer
together and are more appropriate to the
landscape and when I'm comfortable I can
go in and create one large Giant step or
potentially multiple Stepping Stones up
to that house and then I can again
adjust some of these Meandering stones
somewhere a little bit more so they
naturally come to the front of my
Landscaping steps and by creating these
Meandering steps I've provided a single
space to move one of these Grouse trees
exactly in the middle and allow us to
walk around the stunning native
vegetation coming back to image one we
can see we've slowly created that
Meandering path we can go into our
library we can come into our characters
and potentially we can even add some
posed people so let's go summer because
we're obviously on a beach let's pick a
couple people walking past so let's grab
this Ethan bloke drop you into our scene
and let's lad another person next to him
potentially somebody walking as well so
let's keep scrolling this one here will
do let's download her into the scene add
her into our environment as well and
then last but not least let's go back to
our sketch Fab let's go cars and
vehicles let's fly across to the top
back of the road or maybe a little bit
too fast a little bit too far and let's
drop one of these stunning Porsches into
our scene there we go now we have the
start of our first render if I was to
export this out as it is it would look
phenomenal you'd see all of the grass
and all the textures coming into play
and see the sand you'd see the Rippling
water and of course the stunning
background as well now obviously I have
my clipping field turned on so until I
get significantly closer you cannot see
any of that grass and any of that detail
which when you come a lot closer or you
go to something like image 3 and change
our preferences of grass fading from
medium to far we'll see all of that
coming into play absolutely stunning
welcome back to part five where we are
diving deep in to lighting so with twin
motion you basically have a series of
different lighting available to you
predominantly external and internal
Lighting in the last episode we
discussed all of the planting
Landscaping of course thanks to Glow
plants for sponsoring the video but
today we are specifically talking about
the actual lighting because we did
briefly discuss the ambience and also
the global lighting features in our last
video I will dive into interior lighting
in this tutorial so let's break it down
and let's make it super simple if we fly
into any one of our rooms let's start
with the master bedroom because it is by
far the easiest space to light we can do
Lighting in a number of ways first of
all we actually want to make sure that a
lighting appears on the ceiling so we
can do that by going into sketchfab and
searching potentially for something like
a down light once some options appear
you might be able to download something
looks like this that's probably a little
bit too detailed for lights so as an
alternative what we can also do is go
back into our library go to our object
goodwear Primitives and then start with
a base Circle if I simply click once
click OK Escape out of that select our
base Circle and reduce the size by 0.1
and by point one again we're going to
get a very small down light sized object
now it's up to you guys if you want to
have it only as one object or if you
want to duplicate that once more so if I
was to duplicate this drag it down a
tiny bit let's go copy spacing point one
is okay
and then resize Again by 0.9 you'll see
that we've created two identical base
circles now we can drop them both in to
this ceiling and drop one lower than the
other for best practice I like to move
them off just a little bit go to my
metals and then drag and drop my brushed
metal just on to the back layer so then
that way we can change that to a nice
black aluminum base go back to materials
scroll down to the bottom to Neons and
drag Neon 2 onto the smaller base Circle
we created in that instance we can
realign our base circles together now we
have one black base Circle and one
glowing light if we wanted to continue
reducing that in size until we were
relatively happy with the down light we
could and it makes something along those
lines
what we would then want to do is hold
Ctrl shift or any way you want to select
both of these objects in our scene right
click and then we want to create a new
sub container that sub container is
going to be called down white simply
Drag and Drop the Base circle into the
down light from there on in and that way
you can toggle on and off your downlight
in one go in order to move those
elements we do need to select those base
circles again so let's select That Base
Circle once I'm going to put two down
lights directly in front of the bed so
let's fly back around to the underside
of the bed and then duplicate by holding
shift a secondary down light pressing Ok
We're happy with that drag and dropping
it back into down lights so we can group
them and toggle them on and off as we
need we can select all of our elements
and realign once again as we see fit so
I'm genuinely happy with the position of
those two down lights it looks a little
bit odd but bear with me for the moment
we are going to get a little bit more
creative with this down light design
next we you want to come into our
library we then want to go into our
lights panel which is what the
predominant focus of this video is
now inside twin motion you have a series
of different lighting Styles and all of
these cast different shadows cast
different lights and cast different
glows so it's up to you where and how
you wish to use them and what they're
being used for to keep things relatively
generic and simple let's go with either
just the generic Spotlight or pick any
one of these and keep it consistent for
this download type personally I think
this ies7 looks relatively nice so I'm
going to drag it and I'm going to click
it over each one of my downlights that
I've created next I'm going to make sure
they are dragged into my download lights
folder again so I can make life simple
for me to turn them on and off and just
flying around you'll see that down light
is relatively bright even in the daytime
now of course if we click into one of
our light sources we get a new menu and
we get an abundance of different
settings to change now of course twin
motion is overwhelming in this sense and
there's a lot to learn so so don't feel
overwhelmed just simply go through this
step by step it is quite
self-explanatory first of all light
enabled or disabled so ticking that box
will either turn the light on or off
next you'll see the intensity at 300
lumens now from the get-go 300 lumens
might seem like an excessive amount but
if you actually dive into Google and
bring up any of these downlight Lumen
charts a six to nine watt LED down light
which is basically every single down
light you can buy roughly at anywhere
from six all the way through to 12 watts
is 450 through to 800 lumens at the
moment we've got our set to 300 so if we
bump that up to 450 do the same for the
secondary light
we can then move on and I'll explain how
this works once we turn our lights down
attenuation is basically a very fancy
way of saying how far is the light being
pushed from the down light to the ground
in this instance we have approximately
three meter ceilings so we can reduce
that to three meters and you will see
that the intensity of the light isn't
being pushed through the floor if we
increase it's 10 meters it's throwing
that light much stronger
for a much further distance so 2.7
ceilings three meter ceilings will give
you a more realistic you can see these
four yellow lines shooting around the
sides of the LED light and that is
talking about the coat of angle how far
across it spreads the actual light
generally it's a little bit under 180
degrees so 160 is perfect for a down
light if you have a sphere that's
illuminated it'll be obviously 360 and
doing a whole lot more whereas for these
little lights 160 is perfectly fine if
you need a change of both of the lights
at the same time you can hold shift
select both the lights and then adjust
the settings
simultaneously if you've created a copy
moving further down we have our
temperature and our color this one is a
downright Sealy slide it down the lights
go Red Slide the slider up the lights go
white and if you Google different light
temperatures you will find exactly what
each kelvins are generally the LEDs come
in 2 800 kelvin's
410 and 6 000 kelvins it depends how you
like your space to be lit and what the
actual end result you're looking for so
Warm Neutral and cool is a very simple
way of looking at it or you can find
some guides like this that'll basically
tell you how each space should be used
generally three and a half thousand is a
really nice Natural Glow it makes you
feel warm and comfortable I think 3000
is too yellow for me same as two seven
so I like the three and a half
personally once you move into the four
five and the six you're really getting
into the crisp bright hospital grade
lights
and yes they're fantastic but they might
get a little bit critical so three and a
half up to four you're running some
beautiful lights coming back in let's
change this back down to three and a
half thousand kelvins to get a nice warm
light
down the list you're going to have
shadows as your next check box Shadows
is again relatively simple if I come
around
and tick my Shadows box you'll see that
some additional Shadows are being cast
by this light
now the purposes of having a shadow
enabled and disabled is so that you can
actually filter more light into your
scene without having the additional
Shadows created anything from internal
lighting will create a shadow so make
sure you have that ticked for best
results whereas if you're trying to
actually increase the brightness of this
room artificially you can go for
something like an area light so we could
drag and drop an area light directly in
front of that window and once again in
front of this window
that way when we come into our bedroom
and render this image out later down the
track this entire room will be naturally
flooded with light and we won't have to
artificially enhance this image later
down the track now of course these area
lights do not cast Shadows they're left
off whereas if you took it just a whole
bunch of chaos happens that we don't
need so we want to make sure that the
area light is off we want to semi-match
our external lighting to make sure we're
bringing more natural Lighting in for
these sorts of artificial lights six
thousand seven thousand eight thousand
depending on the actual environment
you've set up so if we went back into
our Ambience went into details we'd be
able to see that our white balance is
set to six and a half thousand which
means we could select our two area
lights change it to six and a half
thousand
and then our external area lights would
be matching our external sunlight now
that we have these two little lovely
down lights at the foot of the bed
basically providing a glow to the
walking area we could then go back into
a library go to SketchUp and type in
pendant light to see what kind of
pendant lights are available to us now
honestly sketchfab does not have the
best pendant lights it has a decent
selection of relatively basic stuff but
if you wanted something a little bit
more fancy you'd be going on to 3D sky
or any of the rendering softwares
previously mentioned maybe we want
something like this wicker basket only
that I've just noticed that it's 90
megabytes so we're not going to wait for
that to download let's get a relatively
basic glass pendant light click on that
one to download select it once click and
drag and connect it to our ceiling once
we drag it in of course we need to scale
it properly
rotate it to the correct position and
align it to our ceiling now the texture
of this light could be anything I'm not
really working on interior design at
this point in time it's more so just
teaching you the basics of twin motion
so what we do is we'd copy that light
across allow it to sit as an instance
approximately on the other Bed Head
go back to our materials drag and drop
may be a brass finish on them reduced
illuminance go back to our materials
grab the glass add a reflective glass
around so we can see what's going on and
then what we need to do is fly into our
little Globe go to lights go an
omnidirectional light make sure we're
dropping that omnidirectional light
directly into the globe itself so let's
fly back out select our omnidirectional
light adjust that ever so slightly make
sure our shadows are turned on reduce
our lighting settings and then adjust it
to the other side as well
as you notice the omnidirectional light
is going to cast the shadows in every
direction based on where you place it
however it is immediately going to light
up the scene create the shadows in the
background and make this scene come to
life at night time
now obviously during the day none of
these lights should be enabled you
shouldn't really see them the sunlight
would be more than powerful to actually
illuminate this entire space
so if we went into Ambience for example
and simply turned off auto exposure for
the purposes of this you'd see those
lights starting to come into play as in
nighttime rendering scene now those two
tiny tiny little down lights basically
play no effect from the externals but
when you go inside you've seen you'll
see they cast a nice warm glow directly
in front as does our area light so that
area light we created before if we would
turn that off you'd see quite a lot of
our illumination is gone and most of the
illumination is coming from the Sun out
the front so as you can see these area
lights provide quite a decent bit of
additional illumination without having
to force too many lights or make them
overly bright or overly illuminated
everyone how to select our base circles
and our light fixtures we could go
around add some more lights into this
space copy them across rotate them as we
see fit so now we have two little lights
on that side of the window and we can
drag two more lights over on this side
of the actual room press ok
fly back out you'll see we have six
small lights around the perimeter of our
master bedroom these two at the very end
obviously being way way too close to
that wall because they're casting too
much of a light Shadow onto the wall so
if I was to move them away you'll see
the light being cast less and less now
don't get me wrong lights can cast
Shadows on walls and be wall washers I
just haven't created that in this
instance nor have we selected the right
area light if we wanted a wall washer
maybe we'd go something like this
ies09 so that we could push it further
away and actually wash out that wall in
nice pattern or alternatively we might
put them in the floor and rotate them
180 degrees the negative thing about
this pendant light what I've just
noticed is the fact that we don't have
the ability to add a neon texture to the
globe all of the glass is one Element so
if we wanted to add a neon Tech jar we
could go back to our library back to our
objects back to our Primitives create a
small one meter sphere reduce the sphere
significantly in size to 0.1 go to our
library our materials and add Neon 2 to
the sphere now that we've got Neon 2 to
the sphere we want to illuminate it at
350 and we simply want to drag and drop
it inside the actual pendant itself
and when we have it inside the pendant
we can stretch and adjust it to slightly
suit this shape that we've got inside by
doing so we then get a more realistic
example of that Globe it's still
probably a little bit too dull but we
can work with that because it doesn't
just look like a glass wall we can
obviously adjust as well by increasing
our actual glow in the Globes
and then that way it looks a lot more
realistic if we wanted to create LED
strip lighting as an instance let's fly
over into our kitchen
and talk about LED strip lighting now
there isn't much light going on here
just because I haven't created any so
let's go back to Ambience turn out water
exposure on so we can see what's going
on
and let's say we want to create a little
LED strip light underneath this bench
top first we'd go back into our library
we'd go lights and we'd simply select
our neon light
we can drag and drop that strip light
down below Escape select our neon light
adjust our intensity again to 450 reduce
our length to approximately I believe is
three meters in this bar instance and
then carefully adjust our LED strip
light until we are happy with the
position once again we want to turn our
shadows on because it is a real light it
is working for us it is not working
as an artificial filler and then we can
go back into Ambience turn off our water
exposure to see what that LED strip
light would look like at night time and
as you can see it's a perfect little
space filler it really illuminates that
under bench glow
and at 450 lumens it is quite strong
potentially you might want a very subtle
glow maybe 150 lumens so we can reduce
that as we see fit
now last but not least what I haven't
spoken about is inside all of these
lighting examples in the actual Library
lights part the last section is
miscellaneous if we select miscellaneous
and we're simply going to get a few
options available to us none of these
are really going to make too much of a
difference to your rendering quality
except Dusk to Dawn when you're creating
and exporting some videos
if you select Dusk to Dawn go back to
Ambience and for this to work you cannot
have a hdri sky on so I'm going to
disable my hdri sky
I'm going to turn auto exposure on and
I'm simply going to slide my time of day
Global lighting across so as the sun
beckons into this house in the afternoon
the Shadows are beautiful we get that
golden hour and then we start to go into
Dusk and this LED strip light
automatically turns on so subtle so
beautiful and as you continue to go into
the night
at LED strip light becomes more and more
prominent and more powerful welcome back
to the very last episode in this twin
motion tutorial today we're going to be
running you through exactly how to
create images videos and how to export
them so let's dive straight in down the
bottom you're going to see the little
media icon if you hit the media button
straight away you're going to get
another doc open up I've gone ahead and
created three images which I will go now
ahead and delete so that we can start
fresh and all start on same page first
thing you want to do is just go ahead
and hit that plus button to create your
first scene we have discussed this
before but we're going to go through it
a little bit more detail this time so
let's start by going into our camera
selecting our focal length that we're
happy with in this instance there's 35
mil works really really well it gives
you a nice crop it gives you a nice
composition so we can use 35 5
milliliters camera effects there's not
too much to worry about except maybe
power realism being turned on and
composition overlays turning our grids
just to double check where we are in
this grid after that we can refresh our
scene make sure that we are resetting
our image to this exact position turn
off the composition and head to our
environment I always like to turn auto
exposure off in my renders to be able to
have full control over the scene so
adjusting your exposure ever so slightly
to be able to create the perfect image
for that moment you can go through it
each one of these individual items and
Sliders as we discussed in a previous
tutorial to be able to get a better
render at the end of the day and of
course you should keep your hdri sky on
to be able to get the best results once
you've gone through all of the data and
all the settings you of course want to
increase your format to as large as
humanly possible and then repeat the
same steps over and over so simply fly
around the building fly around the scene
and find new creative angles where you
want to export a render so let's pretend
we want a secondary render from here hit
that plus button we get a new image
continue to fly around to the
potentially the opposite side of this
building from the human scale once again
hit the plus button when you're happy
with the composition same concept
applies internally of course if we fly
inside our building rotate around we can
look out potentially back at our own
building from our bedroom
hit that plus button and then we want to
adjust our actual camera and our focal
length so if we slide this wider we'll
get to see a lot more what's going on at
15 mil we get the full bedroom we get
all of the outside and then we can
refresh it for that focal length now if
we go back into our project and fly to a
different space
hit that plus button once more we will
keep those camera settings we used from
the last image if you want the camera
settings from a previous image just
double click back on that image and then
fly to your next desired image location
once you're there hit the plus button
the new image will jump to the end and
then you will create it using the old
settings now I've gone through that
relatively quickly because we've
discussed all of this in a previous
video what we haven't discussed is video
content creation and how to export so if
we hit quit Media mode come across the
top to our video creation and press
video we can start creating our first
video of course you have Panorama
multiple panoramas a presentation mode
and a phasing group all of these are a
bit more advanced especially the phasing
Group which allows you to basically
create time lapses if things moving so
we won't dive into that in this tutorial
to create a video on the other hand It's
relatively simple and the same concept
we just spoke about for photo so first
of all you want to align and set up your
first video press that plus button to be
able to get the settings tab open run
through these settings make sure they're
exactly as you want them so turning on a
hdri sky adjusting our Auto exposure
manually adjusting that to where we see
fit adjusting little parts and of course
our camera focal length until we're
happy flying back around until the
perfect angle is found to commence our
video next we want to refresh that scene
to capture it and save it now we want to
fly to our second scene imagining as if
the camera was moving in that direction
gliding per se more so than anything so
if we were to fly over to the right hand
side of this building and Center it in
the frame back over in our ocean let's
say we're happy here in the Middle with
our second scene we then want to click
the plus button next to the last frame
by selecting that plus button it will
instruct the camera to move from part
one to frame two in a very gentle motion
you hit play and it will slowly Glide
that video across to exactly that second
frame you've selected if you wish to
continue the camera movement from point
A to point B and thus to point C you
would simply continue along down to your
next scene capture where you are happy
with the general camera angle hit that
plus button once again and then if you
go back to scene 1 press play firstly it
will fly quicker because there are more
scenes to complete in the 10 second time
frame and secondly it will fly from
point A to point B to point C I
mentioned this just in case you do not
want to fly from point B to point C and
you want to jump to point C and then to
a different point D I'll explain that in
a second what you also saw is this video
was a lot quicker because there was more
Saints and the more scenes you add the
quicker the video will continue to be so
to slow down the camera motion you need
to slow down or increase depending on
what you're looking for the video time
stamp so if I increase that to 30
seconds press play it will once again
further slow down and gently Glide
across this architectural design now
like I said if we didn't want to jump
from point C to let's say Point D over
here which might be looking at one of
these flowers in detail and that
beautiful cantilever if I simply click
the plus button I would be flying from
from point C to point D and it would do
this awkward wrapping motion something
that I don't particularly want so
instead I'm going to delete that last
scene I'm going to fly back over to my
flower of course courtesy of globe
plants who is a sponsor of today's video
fly into a little bit of detail with the
building in the background and instead
of pressing the plus button down here
I'm going to press a new video part Plus
you'll see that a secondary part 2 has
been created and then I can slowly fly
around zoom into my flower press my
second plus watch the motion fly very
gently from part one to part two and
then if I was to jump back to the
original Part B in the middle or the
second frame press play let that
eventually slowly get through to the end
of the third frame you'll see it doesn't
naturally move to the flower it
automatically jump Cuts so here you'll
see in three two one it jumps
immediately to that flower
then to repeat that same step let's say
we wanted another jump cut really
focusing on those Globe plants down the
bottom as well as the building in the
background we could once again hit that
plus get a third video apart slowly pan
across onto this beautiful Grass Tree
press the plus once fly to our second
space press the plus again and now when
we watch that scene play through we'll
fly through the grass we'll fly through
the flowers towards the grass tree
slowly isolate and then spin around
of course we can reduce the speed of
that by changing that down to 30 seconds
and then from point A to point B it'll
again continue to slow down and give it
a lot more depth and texture
now I have decreased my settings here in
my preferences to medium quality but if
I bump that back up to Ultra you would
see the increased texture on all of
these Globe plans features so if I press
play you'll see that beautiful stunning
flower in full detail with the
cantilever in the background of course
my computer isn't that powerful to
handle all of these polygons hence why I
reduce it down in quality to medium and
I'm happy for the export to be 100
perfect and not worry about what it
looks like in Twin motion
now once you've gone through and created
your scene you've created your video you
can actually make most of the video here
in Twin motion without having the need
to put it into Premiere Pro and cut it
all up which is phenomenal you get your
timeline here straight away you can then
go down to export now export has all of
your exports in one go
personally I like to recommend exporting
your videos first or your images first
and then the other that way once your
images are exported you can work on them
whilst the video is exporting and you
don't have to wait around for both to
finish so if let's click on our Plus for
the images select all of our images to
export if we then click on the image
itself it will drop down a menu for
three different file formats as well as
details
file format is completely up to what you
guys want to use PNG jpeg completely
fine and acceptable in most cases xcr
I've never personally used but I'm sure
somebody has a use case for it motion
blur works really well if you have paths
created for vehicles and cars so it
creates the motion however I haven't
created any of that in this tutorial so
we'll keep that off refinement again
increases the range of the areas used to
create Reflections for us we can turn
that up to higher and it will create a
much better render Max lighting we don't
want to turn 3D mode on that's if you're
using a stereoscopic 3D viewing device
so you can actually look around if you
tick that you'll get some weird janky
exports such as don't tick 3D mode
unless you need it same kind of deal in
video tap it select all or individually
click on them one by one of what you
want choose your file format export of
course MP4 better than PNG considering
it is still unless you want 30 images
for every second of video Don't Hit PNG
frame rates completely up to you as the
editor of choice for me it's 30 frames
second I'm perfectly happy with that I
don't have to do anything so it actually
works really well with all my other
camera equipment
same details in the drop down menu video
mode you keep it on standard and
refinement you can Chuck it on high if
you want and of course Max lighting all
of these will significantly increase
your export time so just make sure you
turn them off if you want a quicker
render and of course decrease your video
quality if you want a quicker render as
well the one thing I failed to mention
is if you go back to your main menu
you'll see video one which produces the
file format again you can increase your
export times and your export quality by
simply going up to 8K it will take
forever 2K will be nice and quick so
just be mindful of what you're looking
to achieve and how quickly you need the
results
last but not least all you have to do is
come across the bottom hit the start
export button and your journey here on
Twin motion is complete anyway Zane
that's all from me I hope you've enjoyed
it so far I'm going to bring in the
playlist to the side of me so if you're
joining me a little bit later you can
find all the content right here
otherwise smash that subscribe button
drop any comments in the description
down below but like always I'll see you
next Monday